- [Voiceover] The temperature
of a glass of warm water
after it's put in a freezer
is represented by the following table.
So we have time in minutes
and then we have the
corresponding temperature
at different times in minutes.
Which model for C of t,
the temperature of the glass of water
t minutes after it's served,
best fits the data?
So pause the video
and see which of these
models best fit the data.
Alright, now let's work
through this together.
So in order for it,
we see these choices.
Some of these choices
are exponential models.
Some of these are linear models.
In order for a linear model
to be a good description,
when you have a fixed change in time,
you should have a fixed
change in temperature.
If you're dealing with
an exponential model,
then as you have a fixed change in time,
you should be changing by the same factor
so the amount you change
from say minute one to minute two
or from minute two to minute three,
it's not going to be the exact same amount
but it should be the same
factor of where you started.
So let's think about this.
So here,
our change in time is two minutes.
What is the absolute
change in temperature?
So our absolute change in temperature
is negative what, 15.7.
Negative 15.7
and what if we viewed
it as a multiplication?
So what do multiply 80 by
to get 64.3?
Well, I can get a calculator out for that.
So 64.3 divided by 80
is equal to 0.8
I'll just say approximately .8
So we could multiply by
.0.8
This is going to be approximate.
So to get from 80 to 64.3
I could either subtract by 15.7
if I'm dealing with a linear model
or I can multiply by 0.8
Now if I increase my time again by two,
I'm going from minute two to minute four,
so Delta t is equal to two,
the absolute change here is what?
This is going to be not 12.
This is going to be,
my brain isn't functioning optimally.
This was 64.7 then this would be 12
but it's four less than that
so it's 11.6.
Negative 11.6
but if you look at it as
multiplying it by a factor,
what would you have to
multiply by approximately?
Let's get the calculator back out.
So if I said 52.7
divided by 64.3.
Divided by 64.3
is equal to,
that's about .82.
So times 0.82.
So just by looking at this,
I can keep going
but it looks like for our
give and change in time,
my absolute change in the number
is not even close to being the same.
If this was 15.6,
I'd be like okay maybe there's
a little bit of error here.
Data that you collect in the real world
is never going to be perfect.
These are models that try to get us close
to describing the data.
But over here we keep multiplying it
by a factor of roughly .8,
roughly .8.
Now you might be tempted
to immediately say,
okay, well that means that C of t
is going to be equal to
our initial temperature,
80 times a common ratio of 0.8
to the number of minutes that passed by.
Now this is very tempting
and it would be the case
if this was one minute
and if this was two minutes
but our change in temperature each time
is our change in temperature
each time is two minutes
so what we really should say is this is
one way to think about it is that it takes
two minutes to have a 0.8 change
or to be multiplied by 0.8.
So the real way to describe this
would be t over two.
Every two minutes when t is zero,
we'd be at 80.
After two minutes,
we would take 80 times 0.8,
which is what we got over here.
After four minutes,
it would be 80 times 0.8 squared.
In fact, let's just verify
that we feel pretty good about this.
So if we had something like this.
So t
and C of t.
So when t is zero, C of t is 80.
When t is,
well let me just do the
same data that we have here.
When t is two,
we have 80 times,
two over two is one
so it's 80 times 0.8,
which is pretty close to
what we have over here.
When t is four,
it would be 80 .0.8 squared
which is pretty close to
what we have right over here.
I can just calculate it for you.
If I have .8 squared
times 80,
51.2
Getting pretty close.
This is a pretty good approximation.
Pretty good model.
So I'm liking this model.
This isn't exactly one of the choices
so how do we manipulate this a little bit?
Well, we can remind ourselves
that this is the same thing as 80
times 0.8 to the one half
and then that to the t power.
And what's .8 to the one half?
So .8.
That's the same thing as
taking the square root of .8
It's roughly .89
So this is approximately 80
times 0.89
to the t power.
And if you look at all of these choices,
this one is pretty close to this.
This model best fits the data,
especially of the choices going,
this is pretty close to the model
that I just thought about.
Now another way of doing it
that might have been a little bit simpler.
I like to do it this way
because even if I didn't have choices,
we would have gotten to
something reasonable.
Another way to do it is to say okay,
80 is our initial state.
All of these whether you're talking about
exponential or linear models,
start with 80 when t is equal to zero
but it's clearly not a linear model
because we're not changing by
even roughly the same amount every time
but it looks like every two minutes
we're changing by a factor of .8
so we're going to have
an exponential model
so you say okay, it will be
one of these two choices.
Now this one down here you could rule out
because we're not changing
by a factor of 0.8
or 0.81 every minute.
We're changing by a factor of 0.81
every two minutes
so you could have ruled that one out
and then you could have deduced
to this right over here
and you could have said,
look, if I'm changing by a
factor of .9 every minute
then that would have been
.81 every two minutes
which is pretty close to
what we're seeing here
changing by a factor of about .8 or .81
every two minutes.
So once again that's why
we like that first choice.